if you're into fancy cars we're standing
in front of 2012 Tesla and what's more
interesting than the outside is actually
the inside it's being powered by a
system called the NVIDIA Tegra 2
processor or it's actually a
system-on-a-chip this chip is inside
some of the most powerful smartphones
right now and what it's doing inside
cars is providing a system called
infotainment software applications likes
a really high high resolution 3d
graphics for navigation that's more
realistic the ability to detect street
signs like speed limit signs to tell you
how fast you should be driving and also
things like engine diagnostics so you
can know if something's failing inside
your car take her to systems already in
some Volkswagens and some allottees in
the next year or so we're going to see
these in BMWs and Tesla vehicles